la scène kitsch et à l ultime assaut
faty catch mais il ya quelque chose de
spécial dans l'air ce soir
particulièrement lorsqu'on s'exprime au
château de chambord dans l'antre du
génie de la renaissance mort non loin de
là à amboise il ya tout juste un an demi
millénaire qui sait léonard de vinci
c'est même peut être retenue juste là ce
soir où je me tiens en ce moment la
simplicité et la sophistication suprême
la simplicité et l'élégance des heures
du génie de de vinci est mal et tout de
réflexion et de connaissances complexe
mais qu'est ce qui lie cette citation
avec le sujet de montolieu tedx la
biologie synthétique
il s'agit du phénomène d'émergence je
suis neuroscientifique à l'institut
curie et laissez moi vous raconter l'une
des plus incroyables période notre
civilisation émergence le tout vaut plus
que la somme des parties
léonard de vinci a eu de génial de
réunir 2 à 2 des domaines scientifiques
pour en créer de nouveaux ces derniers
ayant des potentialités inédite plus
grande que ce qui n'était permis juste
avant d'ailleurs le terme renaissance si
bien de cette idée de reprendre les
dogmes artistique de l'antiquité peut
aussi désigner cette renaissance des
domaines scientifiques à l'époque
cette renaissance elle a eu lieu une
deuxième fois dans l'histoire et nous
sommes en plein dedans
alors vous avez tous que nous sommes à
l'aube de la révolution technologique la
plus folle de notre histoire vous savez
peut-être moins qu'une partie cette
révolution porte un nom il s'agit de la
révolution and he is et ntic haine pour
nanotechnologies avec pour unité la
molécule voir l'atome b
biotechnologies avec pour noter la
cellule voire l'adn epour informatique
avec pour unité le bit forme de 1 ou 2 0
ou peut-être demain quantique et puis
c'est pour cognitique l'étude du
raisonnement et de l'intelligence
unité le neurone alors un exemple cette
révolution
nbc nous connaissons tous sains et
maintenant de l'informatique et de la
connectique
cela a permis l'émergence de
l'intelligence artificielle en apportant
la théorie des réseaux de neurones et
bien pour la biologie synthétique nous
direz vous c'est la réunion ii le
premier le facile la biologie et l'autre
des techniques d'ingénierie à l'échelle
microscopique et nous reviendrons juste
après alors biologie synthétique ou
comment recréer du vivant peut-être vous
demandez pourquoi
quel est le but de tout ça quels sont
les objectifs sous jacent est bien
appuyé si juste avant vous pouvez
prendre le temps de s'émerveiller devant
la biologie synthétique ça vous dit cool
moi même étant autant passionné par
l'art que par la science
je vous emmener au coeur d'un monde où
les artistes se sont d'autre que vos
propres cellules
alors pour vous remettre juste un peu
dans le contexte je viens donc de
l'institut curie
nous disposons de matériel exceptionnel
de microscopes exceptionnelle a
tellement que j'ai un besoin d'être un
enfant
continuant à jouer avec ses propres
jouets encore aujourd'hui grâce à ces
micro scope l'infiniment petit se
dévoile tout en fluorescence anvers en
rouge sont les neurones les cellules par
excellence du système nerveux
ils sont aussi très dynamique encore en
train de mettre en place le réseau de
neurones en vert juste ici ce sont les
cellules gliales le véritable majordome
de neurones ils sont capables de les
soigner de les nourrir et même de
traiter leurs déchets alors vous voyez
que tout cela est très dynamique et pour
cause il s'agit de cellules
embryonnaires encore en train de mettre
en place le tissu cérébral alors vous
voyez on contrôle pas encore ce qu'il se
passe il ne s'agit pas à proprement
parler de biologie synthétique pour lui
à comprendre vous rappelez quand je vous
ai dit que la biologie synthétique était
la réunion de la biologie et des
techniques d'ingénierie à l'échelle
microscopique un des sous domaines de
leçons de la biologie synthétique c'est
celui des organes sur puce réunion de la
biologie et de la microfluidique alors
une puce comme celle de vos smartphones
et bien quelque part oui la
microfluidique ou l'étude des fluides à
l'échelle microscopique utilise les
mêmes techniques de création que les
plus de votes de vos smartphones l'idée
intéressante c'est que ce n'est pas du
courant électrique qui circulent mais
des fluides et l'idée encore plus génial
de cet organe sur puce c'est que dans
ces fluides
il a directement de véritables cellules
un organe sur puce
ça ressemble à ça donc c'est petit
flexible transparent on ne voit rien et
pour cause
tout est à l'échelle du micromètre un
million de fois plus petit que le m pour
comprendre ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
dessus nous invite à repartir en vidéo
et surtout faites bien attention
regardez la différence avec la
précédente
allez allez vas-y div voilà vous voyez
les neurones avance en ligne droite
nous arrivons véritablement contrôler
l'évolution et la croissance des réseaux
neurones facilement revenons à notre
échelle celle de l'humain reproduire sur
ses puces des micro environnement qui
miment ce qu'il se passe dans votre
cerveau permet bien plus que le progrès
scientifique
cela permet le progrès social
premièrement sur ses puces si nous
testons directement des médicaments et
des traitements
nous pouvons envisager de se passer de
l'expérimentation animale mieux sont
venus directement de véritables maladies
telles qu'alzheimer parkinson vous
pouvez éviter de les induire à de
véritables animaux léonard de vinci il
ya 500 ans disait déjà il viendra un
jour où les hommes comme moi ou les
personnes comme moi regarderont le
meurtre d'animaux comme certaines voyais
toujours de vie le meurtre du main je
vous laisse du temps pour l'avoir fait
alors deuxième présence à douter
en ayant ses organes sur puce et donc du
coup plus davantage de recherche sur les
animaux
nous pouvons vraiment avoir quelque
chose de plus facile à reproduire
réutiliser transporter et c'est grâce à
cela nous ambitionnons vraiment de
réduire drastiquement le coût en
millions et le temps en année que l'on
met à développer des médicaments et des
traitements
et puis enfin troisième potentialités
allons voir plus loin et si sur ces
puces on n'était pas juste de simples
cellule mais des cellules souches
cellules souches
vous savez ces cellules capables de
donner toutes les autres neurones
globules rouges cellules de peau etc
pour des raisons d'intérêt étaient
physiques et mentales qui est évidente
on ne peut pas prélever neurones sur les
adultes en revanche on peut vous
prélever des cellules souches
imaginez la puissance d'avoir vos
propres cellules sur ses puces nous
réagissons tous différemment à une
molécule un traitement une
chimiothérapie ou une allergie
imaginez véritablement la puissance
d'avoir votre propre biologie sur cette
puce alors concrètement le mieux c'était
encore de donner un exemple vous
connaissez iron man
les fans comme moi de super-héros savent
que ces armures ont évolué au fil de
temps portant chacune un nom différent
et bien pour mes organes sur plus je
m'amuse à faire pareil et voici maillot
type jeu 1,19 alors cette puce là les
plus en silicone comme avant mais
dorénavant en collagène il matière bien
pas produite par le corps ainsi bien
plus proche du modèle final qui est
notre corps et puis derrière il ne
s'agit pas à proprement d'un simple
organe sur puce est plutôt d'un
multiples organes sur puce un
comportement pour les muscles un autre
pour les neurones pour permettre la
l'innervation et puis un autre pour un
autre pour les muscles non pour les
vaisseaux sanguins excusez moi pour
mettre la vascularisation alors vous
vous souvenez quand je vous ai parlé des
cellules souches sur ses puces sur cette
puce nous mettons déjà de véritables
neurones humains provenant de véritables
patients dans de véritables des hôpitaux
avec de véritables maladie l'avait
seulement compris nous ambitionnons déjà
de recréer leur maladie
sous ces puces le domaine des organes
sur puce n'est qu'une petite partie du
domaine de vue synthétique qui comprend
notamment un grand pan dédié à la
génétique et vous comprenez bien que
l'espace d'un talk et adx je n'aurais
pas eu le temps d'en parler mais retenez
que sur ses puces alors certes nous
avons des applications en médecine et
entre un sceptique mais aussi dans plein
de domaines agronomie agriculture chimie
des archives production des
bioplastiques de carburant etc et j'en
passe et j'en oublie forcément une aussi
petite chose avec d'aussi grand impact
alors vous l'avez compris ce soir pour
pallier tout cela il faut être un peu
passionné leonardi et déjà toute
connaissance des buts par des sentiments
mais ce soir je réalise quelque chose de
peut-être encore plus important à mes
yeux
vulgariser et démocratise
car il s'agissait car il ne s'agit pas
que vous soyez simplement au courant de
ce qu'il se passe mais que vous puissiez
directement avoir les outils pour
comprendre les grands enjeux de demain
car j'aimerais finir sur cela léonard de
vinci était l'un des plus grands
humanistes de son époque il mettait
toujours l'humain au centre des
préoccupations et de par ses oeuvres il
racontait une histoire c'est de
l'évolution de notre civilisation
aujourd'hui c'est le terme
transhumanisme qui commence à faire
parler de lui
certes le défi éthique est immense mais
sous son approche techno progressiste la
technique la science la motivation le
travail au service du progrès social et
l'humain j'ai pu y découvrir une
approche fondamentale profondément
philanthrope et altruiste qui pensent
véritablement que m faire de la
recherche m de large en maître du temps
pour vous inviter à vous à vos proches
et à n'importe qui d'avoir un cancer ou
une neurodégénérescence a bien plus de
sens en laye bien plus de souffrances
n'ont souhaité que passer de l'iphone 10
à l'iphone
[Applaudissements]
je voulais vous dire que un jour en me
retournant sur la terrasse d'un café
parisien
un café à 9 euros donc un ami m'a dit
que il me voyait comme steve jobs le
fondateur d'apple en train de créer dans
son garage une nouvelle technologie qui
pourrait potentiellement demain changer
la vie de millions de personnes
pourtant je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
de fondamental ferrand ne s'agit pas
simplement d'avoir une technologie sas
une satisfasse uniquement son
utilisateur est saisie d'avoir une
partie de vous qui puisse vous sauver
vous ainsi que vos proches ce soir plus
que jamais l'avenir de notre
civilisation s'inscrit dans la pierre et
dans les circuits microfluidique merci
[Applaudissements]